c'est toute une pièce une pièce vraiment
impressionnante loi sème s'apprête à
inaugurer son tout nouvel orgue norgren
casavant fabriqués à saint-hyacinthe
le concert aura lieu le mercredi 28 mai
notre collègue andré bernard de
l'émission découverte a suivi sa
construction il nous donne la mesure du
travail colossal derrière cet instrument
c'est un chantier par ordinaire ce qu'on
construit ici c'est un son lord en soi
quand on parle de l'instrument nous et
ces messieurs c'est un instrument du
kaki qui pèse m étonne c'est lourd c'est
une grosse machine mais qui doit être
sensible loeb fait 16 mètres de haut
l'équivalent d'un édifice de trois
étages chacun de ces tuyaux étaient
fabriqués à la main
il a fallu quatre ans à la maison
casavant saint-hyacinthe pour mener à
terme sa construction
l'orne qui est à 90% mécanique est un
chef-d'oeuvre de précisions tous les
mécanismes qui actionne les soupapes
doivent être réglées au millimètre près
directeur technique et architectes ont
dû relever de nombreux défis entre août
pour soutenir les tuyaux disposés en
façade dont certains pèsent jusqu'à une
demi tonne
mais le plus grand défi a sûrement été
l'harmonisation de ses 6489 tuyaux de
l'atelier jusqu'à son installation
finale dans la maison symphonique les
harmoniste ont passé des milliers
d'heures pour développer la sonorité de
l'orgue
on espère que on espère que les
spectateurs montréalais
bon ça qu'a péri de toutes ces palettes
de couleurs
on l'a pris ici
olivier latry organiste titulaire du
grand orgue de notre dame de paris
les experts conseillent pour l'om sera
aux commandes de l'ordre de pierre b
durant premier concert inaugural
mercredi prochain les mélomanes seront à
même de juger si le mariage entre
l'orgue
l'orc est et la maison symphonique et
réussit ici andré bernard radio canada
montréal